[Music]
it says here that they have quantified
our digital footprint so that we can see
the impact that we've had on the
Internet did we pay for this this is
what happens when you google rhett and
Link that's me and you buddy yeah buddy
nineteen million five hundred dollars
and results and it only took point five
four seconds that's a lot of thinking
time for a computer that's like a few
lifetimes of regular humans this is what
happens when you google good mythical
morning 169 million results is this why
when people come up to us in public they
don't say hey it's rhett and Link they
say hey you're the guys from good
mythical morning we have a brand of
problem one section that comes up is
people also ask uh-huh and you answer
these questions what time does good
mythical morning upload we uploaded 3
a.m. Pacific Standard Time otherwise
known as 6 a.m. Eastern Standard Time
because that's when the day begins for
the world will the world a rhettandlink
married yes not to each other so no not
to each other you Jesse and Christy how
tall is Rhett from a good mythical
morning what about me why don't people
ask how tall I am just cuz I'm shorter
than this one I'm 519 and link is 512
so I'm 7 inches taller so that's some
math I want you to take you to do that
point five seconds according to Google
people also searched for these okay all
right I'm interested oh we got a guess
who they are teaching chomp cheap ripoff
of Fallon I don't know smosh smosh okay
that makes sense
Tsukasa yeah cuz we bought smugly bought
them yeah
Ian of Smosh he works for us
Thomas read Thomas read this brings up a
great story one time we were in a voodoo
store in New Orleans and a girl who had
had one too many of those really tall
fancy drinks that you get on the streets
from Orleans came up to us and she was
like aren't you guys Thomas and Rhett
and we said yes
all right applier Markham okay Wow we
don't cry as much as he does no we could
stand the crime wars and finally I guess
in dealings
anyone who has any sort of relevance on
YouTube PewDiePie it was the thing they
searched for before they got to us all
right he also search for these 18 other
people the reason they search for the
guy panic is a disco dude because people
say you look like him
yeah people reason people search for
Britain Buchanan is because he did
cousin yeah and he's a he's a soon to be
really famous singer the reason that
because he's my cousin for post Malone
is because post Malone was on our show
he's our bud man I mean he hasn't called
recently because he's been real busy but
you know like he could call Billy Eilish
is also searched for because she's super
hip with the jimsy course we're lit at
speaking directly to the jimsy right all
right this is a Google Trends graph of
our names searched over time in the US
looks like we've peaked yeah we peaked
in 2014 which is great news to hear you
didn't have to show us this data well
here's what happened there I can explain
this data that was two years in a good
mythical morning and that was when we
made some very specific changes in good
mythical morning and also YouTube made
some very specific changes in the types
of videos that they were rewarding
rewarding because they start the
algorithm started rewarding videos that
were longer and kept people on the site
so we were making a lot of videos that
were like 10 to 15 minutes long and we
basically just got really lucky
there are 395 images of us on
great sorted by oldest this image from
April 2011 comes up hey I remember this
event this is um malaria no more you had
different hair you also had a lot less
beard yeah you really you really let
yourself go yeah I mean it's been eight
years yeah and it looks like it right
okay we're on our what we used to call
our main channel the rhett and Link
YouTube channel yeah I barely remember
because we don't upload anything over
there for four years four point five
eight million people over there just
waiting on the music video come on guys
well haven't do the music videos what
happened to the sketches do you remember
joining YouTube on June 5th 2006 yes the
first video that we uploaded in 2006 was
us and our friends going to Tennessee
and throwing a large rock off of a dam
it was illegal on several fronts don't
recommend it no one watched that video
zero reaction even in the video the rock
phone we're like oh there's a little bit
but no one watch this on youtube these
are our three most viewed videos on
YouTube you know what they are okay I
would say they are the OCD song no yep
the I'm on vacation song and the epic
rap battle of nerd vs. geek no game show
cheaters me eating a scorpion and then
us eating something else let's see my OC
- 151 million views it was right so I
was not nervous is gay ohoo ohoo is
right again that's me okay what are five
million views oh I was right about all
three oh cool that's 29 million views
good with numbers and who's not huh goda
thought it's me eating the scorpion how
many views did I get less than twenty
nine million apparently we collected all
the comments from those video
and made a word cloud one here are some
words we noticed sandwich geek nerd
protector the biggest one is protector
let me just start there
why is protector the biggest word link I
haven't told you this but I am ear
protector I was sent here to keep you
safe I think this is from one of the
lyrics in the rap battle sandwich so Oh
would you like a sandwich I ask ya Oh
sandcastle yeah there's a sand castle in
the in the opening scene of I'm on
vacation there's also a sand castle
hidden in every single video we've ever
made yeah which is close to 3,000 videos
sandcastle on lookout for a single one
we compared searches for rhett and Link
and good mythical morning overtime okay
so they follow a similar you know shape
if you will you know first of all we
can't lose here because we're both you
know we're both yeah yeah we're both so
let's stop and feel bad that's something
that we made it's better than alright
alright we should actually feel good
about that right and larger than
ourselves that's right alright this is
what you're known for on IMDB can we
explain wings known for good mythical
morning
it's a writer okay sure yeah Breaking
Bad the middle school musical yeah as a
writer and we wrote that along with
Rachel bloom believe it or not she's
gone on to bigger and better things the
mythical show 2013 we took a break from
good mythical morning and we did a
half-hour show once a week for ten weeks
that's called the mythical show we
started hiring people to help us do
things in Los Angeles we hired Stevie
who ended up becoming our longtime
creative partner and led to a lot of the
changes that we made with the mythical
morning
way back in 2008 it's when this came out
but we filmed a documentary where we
were searching for miss Locklear who was
our first grade teacher who introduced
us but we didn't use phone or the
internet only face-to-face contact
word-of-mouth we also did not shoot it
in HD as you can tell by the blu-ray DVD
cover the most liked video of us
any platform is the my OCD song I knew
that
should this be our most liked video my
OCD is a song that really struck a chord
people seem to really enjoy it it
validate a lot of OCD out there which
that's what I want to do is that's the
life that I live it gets me a little
clump just talking about it it
represents music and sketch together
right that was we've kind of went
through a phase there we were like hey
let's do some music videos but let's put
you know some narrative portions on each
side of them and that we then went on to
incorporate into our series buddy system
and other things that we're working on
so yeah video here are the top hashtags
when you search rhett and Link on
Instagram
okay hashtag readily that makes sense
hashtag Rhett mcLaughlin
hashtag Rhett hashtags Rhett Butler
hashtag Rhett Atkins Rhett Akins and
Thomas Rhett and retro Roy I just can't
help but notice it there's one my name
is only in a search when your names
there whereas your name appears a lot
without my name do you want me to make
you feel better about that yeah I kind
of do because I have an explanation yeah
make me feel better your name protect me
your name's your name is link what are
there a lot of on the Internet
pretty much what does the internet
consist us Oh links yeah Instagram
cancels me up right here are some rhett
and Link plushies we found on Etsy oh
that's fancy yeah we will those are our
likenesses save that link we'll be
sending it along to our CEO after this
how much how much did it cost how much
does a I would say Oh
$48 or interest oh let me say $48 you
feel it for the pair for the pair I'm
going to now we would we would only
charge $32 but you know this isn't our
venture right now I
28 $28 41:25 this listing is for one of
my Rhett or link felt monster dolls if
you want both
please order to class 8250 for the pair
so we under shot it you're gonna
discount see we got our belly buttons
exposed down there that's what's up in
the price you get a little a little
peaky Peters only one left link okay how
do you feel about our impact on the
internet where he did say you're a
particular impact on the Internet has
been completely avoided because Dana
because of your name which is I think
that's the biggest takeaway here the
data is an unapologetic loved one they
don't care about your feelings and just
slam you with it it's the unfeeling
conscience of people's best intentions
just out there in the form of math
listen when we're all gone when the last
human is naked and whimpering in a hole
you know what will still be around
roaches yes and math what yeah that's
what happened here today link we saw the
end
[Music]